months and months ago I deleted my
original Facebook account and then I
realized that in order to admin the
corridor page I still needed a personal
one so I tried to make a fake one
Facebook shut it down hard your Facebook
account I just went to my Facebook page
and it was this we're concerned about
security that was out of that security
concerns we're doing this for you thanks
guys
sorry we've only gotten over a hundred
million views on Facebook in the last
two months why would that mean anything
day was the day to kick off color
grading on lifeline submitted media at
10:30
walk in the room sit down I haven't done
a lot of TV stuff before you know we do
all YouTube videos but it was expecting
that but they sit down talk about looks
twelve episodes and different scenes and
all that kind of stuff I walk in the
room and all prepared they chat about
five more minutes ago all right looks
like you got a lot of work to do so I
got to leave it to it and then every
starts getting up I'm just like the hose
weird here is the story what happened
when I tried to make a Facebook account
it didn't really work no see it all
started when I
I cancelled my account in March because
I didn't really like the platform and I
didn't really want to use it and then I
tried to make another one this admin the
four doors page why I don't know I'm
going to go back to the beginning and
I'm going to tell you what happened and
then maybe you can help me understand
why all this has gone down the way that
it is good job Facebook I wasn't really
using the platform
I really have a need for it so I
cancelled my account but then we still
have the corridor page and I really
wanted to be able to put our videos on
there we feel that Facebook is going to
be a place where people are watching
videos more and more there's a lot of
people on that platform that aren't here
on YouTube and we just want to make sure
that our videos get in front of them so
they can enjoy what we do but is it
worth a year of your time you know we'll
find out well as you all know in order
to manage a company page you need to
have a personal profile page on Facebook
so I said okay I'll sign back up again
make a company account that anyone can
use from the company to manage the
company page the official page still
have to do the finishing touches I got
paint everything and make it all up the
other going to figure out how to get
everything on here nice secure and then
I'll be done if anyone knows a better
way to do this comment below and don't
forget to subscribe I printed everything
level so I can just connect these two
pieces together basically here and align
everything outfit you lined up I think I
got a scent definitely need to stand
that little edge down there it's good
very big it should make it kind of like
a sniper kind of situation I think it's
weird because like it freaks me out
constantly seeing the three models turn
into like real life objects scaling is
always a difficult thing it's constantly
adjusting and doing out in 3ds max real
life it's one size you're stuck with it
this one for now Giselle I think I think
a little bit bigger than I was expecting
and some of my mock-ups it's a little
bit smaller I mean I think pretty cool
because also imagine like wires coming
out of this or running along
and garden you seem like any of the
concept art for Elysium there's a lot of
really cool ideas and a lot of unused
ideas things the triangular thing is
inspired for real it's a real gun part
that I know it's basically called like a
gen 3 Delta handguard or forearm and
what it does is get the handguard for
the rifle that is completely triangular
today I've no idea where the design came
from but it's not like this cool 70s or
80s setting but it gives us very
interesting feel because you never see
triangles on weapons harshly it's not
very often hey Christy yeah this what
I'm talking about
click the FAL yeah right is def is like
vintage vibe to it I just love that
weird triangular shape it's a screams
heritage and honor trust durability
craftsmanship so instead we shot with a
bunch of look-up tables from a pack
that's one of our favorite packs online
set a lot on the channel I'll say it
again it's I WL PB ap liked it so much
I'm able to actually remember the random
collection of letters a nickname
throughout the processor they get when
they color great this piece let's just
have them work from the look of tables
that we shot with on set because they
already look really good and it'll save
them a whole bunch of time so I made a
fake account called Corey hunter from
that account we uploaded literal
Bohemian Rhapsody to Facebook and did
really well it got 35 million views and
that account didn't have a photo a real
name or any friends and then all of a
sudden right after that video boom your
account has been disabled for your own
protection the moment I sat down in this
room I asked like toy guys working from
the look of tables at all and goes no
you notice there's a little bit of noise
hopefully skin tones are living off I
wanted to have some more control so I
rebuilt the whole thing myself and it
looked great on the screen and I
realized that we were dealing with true
professionals and asking them to work
from the look-up tables didn't make any
more sense and it did this really really
weird thing where it said upload a photo
of yourself and we'll review it and then
once we decide that your accounts
legitimate will enable it for you again
I upload a photo of me send it to them
my account was disabled for like three
days I went to log in or to see what the
status was
had just been permanently disabled for
good that either happened because it was
a fake name it was didn't have a real
photo it didn't have enough friends or
they saw that we uploaded a video that
did really really well and then the
algorithm caught it as being a bot films
more of like a specific author detail
yes like it's more tailored like whereas
television it's all the most effective
dollar per minute production out there
they come in and within like days of
pumping out entire half-hour episodes
that millions people watch it's a very
well oiled machine big vlogs do a good
job of getting all their minutes for
their dollars and like being really
efficient at some pumping out content
it's like no TV as it's be anyways make
drove all the way out here to record
some behind the scenes so the color
grading I walked in I said hi every
stood up I left and here we are standing
outside there's very quick hop in the
car and drive back home for 45 minutes
be there it was weird because it only
happened after the account was totally
fine and then I uploaded that video and
then it gave me problems I made three
more accounts under my real name with my
real email with real friends all of
those accounts got disabled literally
under the exact same circumstances
couldn't figure out what this weird
weird problem was so finally I reached
out to somebody that might know somebody
over there no man konna to dress the
same Amiga channel really well wrapped
up here from mic pouch from Philadelphia
on recent videos and requested art for a
blank white wall enclosed find my
original pen-and-ink drawing of grumpy
Nico and Sue's Brandon from the node
video super 5 Chuck Norris vs t-rex
please give the brain and drawings to
Brandon the day of my hair was shorter
and that ramen hadn't ran like a lot Oh
pump it up
I have a gift my fan for you man
yes yeah I bet that Tyrion is not
Targaryen in any way whatsoever
Brandon however thinks that tyrion is
Targaryen at least in some way and we
made a $50 bet that's the table in gold
one Rock one gram of gold
enjoy your thank you it's literally it's
August right now I've been trying to get
a Facebook account all year I send it
over to directly to somebody at Facebook
they flip the switch over there log on
my accounts working fine I go great four
hours later I come back and it then
threw me into a new algorithm glitch
loop put in a phone number then Facebook
contact me at that number with a
verification code it was supposed to
take me through to my account but
instead all it would do when I would
enter that verification code is it would
take me back to the beginning of the
loop so after all this trouble it was
still family and this Monday I get to
the studio and I see that I have an
email notification from Facebook you
have five new friends on Facebook or
whatever those you know those emails are
that you get they click on it and it
takes me to my active Facebook page no
one knows how that happened the weirdest
part is you can't get ahold of anybody
over there we don't have very good
ventilation in the studio our workshop I
think has like a single tube that goes
up to roof or ventilation so when you're
working on stuff where you're creating
dust they're using paint so I've added
up it all swirls around in there and be
pretty gnarly if you're not wearing a
mask it's very unhealthy you know you
don't want to breathe in paint just like
like my little scope here applied some
of that SEC 3d here definitely smoothing
things out you know I'm just going to
give a coat pin of two here and be able
to give this guy a little bit of color
since I printed it in white if you're
ever painting anything I always want to
sand the object you're about to paint
especially with spray paint giving it a
little bit of that rough edge really
helps things stick to it no matter what
it is so I have a paint and primer as my
base coat here with a layer of plastic
for like last two three
I don't know it's cool having that
little grippy stuff so you might want to
take a step back I don't want to catch
you in the last year you know
everyone's got their own little style I
like to do the very rapid movement that
way each times the pain is hitting it
and always like the smallest amount
possible hitting it at once prevents
build-up prevents dripping kind of gives
me a lot more of an even coating
speaking of which right I know so wrap
this thing up here it's a little bigger
than I was expecting it to be but it's
pretty cool I feel like this whole thing
was kind of inspired by seeing like the
neill blomkamp shorts I think really the
biggest thing right now in dealing with
this project the biggest challenge in
putting this together it's really just
it's the size of the printer there
that's what I'm gonna have to do next
kind of a blend of old and new what if
you guys are digging these projects
don't forget to subscribe because we're
going to certainly be playing around
with this a lot more trying to create
some new designs if you have any
thoughts on cool tactical combinations
for sci-fi props or weapons let us know
we might try and make one of those
you're going down Carmichael you are
going down sir you know exactly did you
change the desktop yeah under computer
yeah doughnut dive call Michael you're
going down
I don't know what you're going to get
yet but you're going to get it you're
going to get got hard it can take our
camera like that
you
[Music]